what's going on with real vision ro
vision is amazing
so lots going off we've just come off
that retirement campaign because there's
something really really important for us
because this entire retirement narrative
is very big we have done a lot on this
you know we've been very early on this
coronavirus the economic impacts the
volatility stuff you know we've been
looking a lot this and we don't drive
that narrative per se just you know it's
our guest driving the narrative so
people have been coming well in advance
and that's usually how it works with
religion people go god those guys are
bearish and then they were really right
and it's not again I don't drive that
narrative I'm just one of the
contributors that appear on it so that
that's going on and then we've just
launched membership tiers which has been
a great thing for us because it was a
confusing journey where we had a
different product line macron signers
and one called think-tank and then you
get the emails for that and so anyway
we've got this beautiful journey now you
come as a real vision member and you go
to religion plus where you get a lot of
these live broadcasts we get much more
to the you know timeliness more access
to our guests then we go into something
called Pro which is much deeper more
access and then we have something called
the blacklist the blacklist and yeah and
the blacklist is like a super-high-end
kind of concierge membership club which
we have members all around the world and
we do these incredible events I think
your SCO's hosting one in Napa next and
next couple of weeks for a bunch of
these people so that's it that's been
really good so that whole journeys been
fantastic and we also launched as maybe
well no we've now got a free version
that's on both our website we'll roll
vision calm and on YouTube and we
launched that and we've got five million
views in our first month when we kind of
we're like wow five million views on
YouTube
yeah and it's now settled at the moment
about two million views
yeah wow that's a lot well we went
promoting it
it's came from nowhere yeah and while
you're taking the interviews and put
them on YouTube we were taking it once
we started actually doing a bit of
effort with it but it's the same content
and we found that our long-form deep
dive the interview content actually
would that's just about to change our
benchmark interview is going to be our
free show so that interview will have
two of those out a week because we do
number of different formats we have
expert views blah blah but the the
interview will be free then we've built
a widget to embed on third-party
websites
financial websites we're just trying on
Zero Hedge right now where they embed
the widget and relevant videos on the
site the free videos so to give us
enormous scale in distributing free
videos because on the other side we're
working with corporate partners by like
JP Morgan Thompson Reuters for affinity
of whole bunch of asset management firms
and FinTech firms creating videos for
them and distributing videos so we're
doing a lot of that work as well and
that's really you know a really exciting
business but a live events business
going as well a whole bunch of stuff so
you know a lot of people just know us
for the video channel that we've got a
whole bunch of stuff going around it
we're we're we're basically looking at
the entire world's financial world pivot
to video mmm everybody's moving to video
it's a revolution that's going on even
your podcast has gone to video you know
everything goes to video every financial
services firm has to go to video
everything that gets consumed is moving
to video videos like it's like the
spinning you know wheel of death it's
sucking everything into it and we're the
only people who really do what we do and
you know have a lot of experience doing
it so all the financial services firms
have been reaching out to us whether
it's that it's very high quality I'm a
subscriber I actually won't even let you
guys give me a cop
membership I tell them I'm [ __ ] pain
so I'm trying to give you the free we'll
get so expensive let's face it all you
get
it's $180 z8 the price is actually about
to go up to 240 my guys always gotta go
he's got a pitch I love it alright so
$180 what is the real vision calm yeah
right and Cibola a month trial run out
no-brainer that's a no-brainer
yeah alright what um what's the one
thing that you want people who is the
average investor the person who's hey
look I have a personal portfolio I've
got you know my savings a little bit of
investment capital etc what's the one
thing you think they should just tell
themselves over and over and over again
for the next 18 to 24 months cash is
king
cash is king just for the average guy
right don't overcomplicate it don't try
and beast and Rocco Miller don't try and
be the hero if you've got a bit of
speculative money that you want to bet
on the side to learn how this all works
fine do that there's some opportunities
and we've gone through them at length
here the reality is the best thing you
can have is cash yeah and the other
thing the other piece of advice that
helped me my whole life is if you ever
get in a situation where you can afford
to pay off your mortgage do that first
amongst all things because then nobody
can take anything away from you you have
a house to live in you can still work a
bar job you can do something and your
life is protected and working from a
position of strength is always better
than working from a position of weakness
a lot of people encrypt I don't like
Warren Buffett but he he's probably one
of the best if not the best investors in
our lifetime and right now he's sitting
140 billion in cash about a third of
their assets let's tell you something
right well here's what I joke about all
the time when whenever anyone brings
them up these long Treasuries therefore
right yeah well here's here's what the
way I look at it is forget the Bitcoin
step for a second right now ad nauseam
talked about how like you pie shouldn't
take technology advice from a guy
doesn't use technology so I just put
that aside for a second
going back to your idea of doubling up
and getting super aggressive and having
that risk profile etc guys like him they
salivate over situations that we think
are about to play out because he's
sitting there with a bunch of cash all
of these asset prices are gonna drive
down he's going to make the rules and
he's going to most likely be able to
drive incredible deals for himself and
for his shareholders and the average
person doesn't necessarily have to be
Warren Buffett but I think your point
about cash is king there's a protection
element to it but there's also a lot of
people right now who say you know what
I've got enough cash where I want to buy
an investment property I want to do this
I want to do that etc it's probably
going to pay off to be patient yeah it
because things and even if you don't
have a lot of money they'll say well
what's the point of my ten grand you
know what can I do with that well guess
what
Insp 30% lower is gonna be helped a lot
well that's gonna help a lot the other
thing is maybe you want to go on that
trip around the world well but the time
coronavirus goes those flights are going
to be a free nation
so we'll be free well that's right so
you know that whatever it is the ability
to have money when nobody else has it is
extremely powerful even as a small micro
level yeah then it's very fair real
vision calm what's your Twitter handle
that's Raul RA o UL GMI I'm about to go
back and need to write this I wrote
tweet this morning all the math is wrong
because I wrote it too early in the
morning yeah I'm just better put it out
it's quite shocking tweet about
comparing the virus to Spanish flu so
watch out for that as soon as I go back
to my hotel I'll do that and I need to
go to the office and actually gonna do
real work to someone oh this has been
good all right you've been here for an
hour 45 minutes you're a legend I'm a
huge fan of real vision obviously you
you nailed the the bond call there and
that was probably the best call of my
life he thinks I'm gonna give myself for
that path oh you know what a question
somebody had
I got to question for you before I let
you go what is the worst investment
decision you've ever made and what did
you learn from it [ __ ] there's too many
of those no but like either you can
qualify worst as the stupid like your
site or the amount of corny one of the
good ones that's like bought I was in
London 2003 for and I decide that
Spanish property market looks good
I've already bought home that I'm a
house our house by start thinking that I
want to buy an investment property and
on a golf course because apparently
that's what people want but I [ __ ]
hate golf it's one of the worst things
in earth with the worst cultures I've
ever come across
so I hate golf so I buy two apartments
on a golf course off plan because it was
near the house and of course now not
thinking through that really when people
come to the Mediterranean coast of Spain
the key is in the word coast and not in
a Golf Resort you know five miles from
the coast and so I bought them and I
thought yeah I'll just rent them out
because there's all these golfers though
to do that obviously everybody I thought
of doing the same thing at the same time
in Spain and by the time the apartments
were completed about 2006 great timing I
can rent them there so 2005 maybe I
couldn't let them so the the implied
yield at home my head is like look at me
smart I'm a hedge fund guy support these
BOTS you know I'll get a 5% 7% yield any
way I'll just carry it and it'll be fine
and then over time the price will
appreciate just couldn't rent them at
all and then I ended up selling both of
them for the same price I paid one of
them
because I keep just because I just
wanted to get rid of the damn things
because I hated them so much because I
didn't like golf their apartments that I
would never use myself they were but
that's gonna happen a lot I think of a
next 24 months yes and because a lot of
you know idea about that is I made an
investment something I shouldn't have
made an investment in you know the
certain things I couldn't there's other
property I could have invested in that I
wouldn't have made such a stupid mistake
was something I couldn't rent and
couldn't sell him he was on the market
for three years trying to sell out four
years trying to sell it when the whole
of Spanish property was offered only
most important book and luckily I didn't
have a mortgage because if I'd had debt
then I'm screwed
most important book you ever read most
important
bonfire of the vanities why because it
is the that's not I'd say stood out and
so different answer tomorrow because it
is it shows the humility that we all
have to have when we all think we're
geniuses are amazing for whatever reason
that we do that narrative that we have
our vanities everyone has to realize
they're not real as for that humility in
all things is actually what you should
strive to achieve for without it being
your defining factor oh he's so humble
cuz usually that's for fake last
question that you get asked me a
question we're done
aliens you believer if I like if I
believe in probabilities and of course
why well just because permutations and
combinations are infinite so therefore
there's infinite outcomes so of course
that's fair just a math equation it's
just a math equation yeah I agree you
know it's it's not difficult the
question all started I have asked over
Turner people this now because I was
laying in bed one day and I thought
everyone always asked about aliens but
you know there's intricacies to life and
so here on earth we have pets
- there's humans and animals do you
think there's like alien pets I think
that they're walking around and they've
literally like domesticated other - all
pets pets
well is this a symbiotic relationship
where they're using else you're going
down the rabbit hole that's exactly why
I asked the question what question you
got for me to finish up when is the next
time you're gonna get a plane
and so all right when do you actually
think you'll fly again okay so you'll
love this last year did a hundred twenty
flights I think and told myself I'm not
gonna travel this year I had to go to a
board meeting in San Francisco in I
think was Jan you were and of January
I've never in my life
bought a mask I've never worn a mask
I've never done anything I got on the
plane and I couldn't find in ninety five
messages they were all sold out here in
New York so I literally was like what
else can i buy well I'll just buy a
[ __ ] dust mask I guess whatever I can
get doesn't really do anything
put it on had a hood pulled it real
tight and I literally sat there with
like my hand sanitizer in my hand I was
like the germaphobe of the year right
cuz I just freaked out I just didn't
understand it whatever flew back I have
since taken two more trips so I'm on
three trips for the year I'm supposed to
go at the end of March back to San
Francisco next week I'm supposed to go
to DC where all these things I'm
seriously considering just saying I'm
not going anywhere I'm going back to
Cayman and I'm not this kind of guy I'm
not a prat yeah just not the guy I'm
usually a risk taker when it comes to
this don't give a [ __ ] I like going to
war zones you know I really I don't mind
I'm gonna matter Cayman and I'm not I
was supposed to be going to Napa Valley
to the to something in March not going
I'm a global macro mr. roundtable in
Majorca I've cancelled it I'm supposed
to be spending a month in the summer in
Italy and Spain I'll go it yeah just
because I don't know yeah and the
outcomes aren't quite I don't want to be
its again I Bing ill it's not the thing
that I fear it's being suddenly then not
be able to get home that's a one serious
issue right if you get quarantined
the other thing is I live in a country
as a foreigner
now let's you back there my little
letters back they might throw us out
because the medical system can't deal
with us there's a whole lot of unknowns
that is really complicated so I yeah I
just I don't know the answers real
vision dot-com go subscribe
unless it's happier than it it's not
always like this Raul is is a legend
thank you so much for doing this
I thoroughly enjoyed it all those a bit
apocalyptic although it is what it is